go hi i'm matt and this is tom and we're
playing chess clock jenga
chessblock jenga is a massive
improvement on ra how did you do that
that fast
chess clock general is a massive
improvement on regular jenga you lose if
ah if your timer runs out on your clock
on the chest clock
or if you're not the tower over now
chest clocks work for those who don't
know by having two separate clocks that
only count down
on your own turn so
currently we're pretty much exactly tied
because i had a couple difficult
moves matt had a couple difficult moves
but right now his clock is counting down
40 seconds
and mine isn't so i've got a little bit
of breathing space a little bit
but that doesn't mean i can't still lose
if i do
something like that and the trouble is
matt
is very good at finding that
block that is just not in there with the
rest of the tower and having said that
matt you're still 10 seconds behind me
oh oh of course you got that one right
wonderful uh
oh can i take that yes yes i can take
that one so you can't take from the top
two levels
same with regular jenga but there we go
oh but other than that every block is
fine
matt you are still 10 seconds oh god i'm
laid behind
yeah tommy you got 25 seconds i'm fine
17 for you
it's absolutely fine
13 seconds matt so all tom needs to do
is not make the tower fall over and my
timer will run out quickly
oh assuming i can find a block to move
ah
ah 15 seconds tom ah
okay no i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine i'm
fine 12 seconds back oh it's not full
five four three
two one
[Laughter]
oh come on and that is chess clock jenga
it's so much better than the original
you